en la mañana seguía estando
prácticamente vacía como lo había estado
ayer gran parte del día el alcalde de la
ciudad había dicho que gran parte de la
población al menos el 70% se había ido
esperando un ataque ruso en ese año del
aniversario Cuando comenzó esa invasión
a gran escala el 24 de febrero del 2022
ayer no atacaron los rusos ni sonaron
las alarmas pero sí fue un día lleno de
sentimientos en los cuales los
ucranianos en todas las partes del país
recordaron Cómo había sido ese primer
día de esa invasión que para muchos
dicen pudo haber sido el día más difícil
de sus vidas hoy a las 9:30 de la mañana
volvieron a sonar las alarmas por muy
poco tiempo sin embargo pues no se sabe
que haya pasado nada por lo menos en los
alrededores de la ciudad de si esto
llega en un momento en que la ciudad de
gersón en el suroccidente del que es
sistemáticamente atacada fue otra vez
atacada fuertemente por congrats esta
madrugada y lo mismo sigue sucediendo en
la región del Don Vasco donde esos
enfrentamientos siguen siendo constantes
en la población de chasillar cerca de
bacmut hay una persona muerta también en
bakú y así en varias poblaciones de esta
región sin embargo el tema predominante
sigue siendo China y esa propuesta de 12
puntos para salir de
negociar para salir de esta guerra y que
ha sido rechazada por accidente
especialmente por Estados Unidos sin
embargo el presidente Bordo de dormirse
ayer en una rueda de prensa daba la
bienvenida que china empezara a hablar
de Ucrania sin embargo uno de sus
asesores decía hoy que esta propuesta no
era viable por lo menos hasta que Rusia
se retire de todos los territorios que
tiene invadidos en Ucrania